[Música]
este 11 de Julio se conmemora el Día
Mundial de la población una fecha que
fue proclamada en 1989 cuando el mundo
superaba los 5.000 millones de
habitantes ya somos más de 8 mil
millones de seres humanos en el planeta
y para analizar a las principales
problemáticas que enfrenta la población
mundial y las tendencias que se han
modificado en las últimas décadas
conectamos con Pablo Salazar Canelo se
les representante del fondo de población
de las Naciones Unidas en Guatemala
además es economista Muchísimas gracias
Pablo por estar con nosotros y comienzo
preguntándole Cuáles son esas
principales problemáticas que
enfrentamos como población mundial
Ángela gracias por la invitación
realmente Hay cosas importantes a
celebrar en el contexto del día de la
población pero también muchos temas
pendientes y desafíos que quedan todavía
para el mundo dentro de los temas a
celebrar el hecho de que la población
mundial se está desacelerando y que en
general se observa una tendencia a que
se vaya consolidando esta idea de que
las mujeres tengan la posibilidad de
decidir Cuántos hijos quieren tener
cuándo quieren tenerlos Y con quién
quiere tenerlos sin duda eso explica en
gran medida los descensos y los cambios
dentro de la fecundidad y por lo tanto
también en el desaceleramiento de la
población mundial por otro lado los
cambios en la estructura de la población
también están conllevando a que tengamos
fenómenos nuevos que estamos viendo
junto con temas a celebrar por ejemplo
la el incremento de la esperanza de vida
en la población mundial También está
implicando en nuestras sociedades
tienden a envejecer más porque tenemos a
vivir más tiempo y evidentemente están
también haciendo menos personas jóvenes
entonces lleva a que repensemos nuestro
sistema de protección social los
sistemas de Cuidado la forma como
tenemos que enfrentar el futuro y
también como tenemos que enfrentar las
desigualdades que persisten todavía en
nuestros países Bueno usted mencionaba
las decisiones o la determinación de las
mujeres para tener un no maternidades
pero otro tema que también es seguro
está por debajo de la mesa es la baja en
fertilidad que se ha dado en algunos
lugares del mundo podría ampliarnos un
poco más acerca de esto porque porque es
otro problema mientras que se necesita
más población joven para que saque
adelante la sociedad
más que problema es un desafío no en
términos de cómo debemos adaptar hay que
pensar que la lógica de Derechos Humanos
lo que lleva a concebir es que las
mujeres tienen el derecho de decidir
Cuántos hijos desean tener Y con quién
tienen tenerlos en qué momento de su
vida quieren tenerlos en buena medida
entonces las condiciones partículas que
tienen otras sociedades y también las
desigualdades de género se traducen en
que en algunos casos y en algunos países
la fecundidad deseada eventualmente sea
mayor que la fecundidad observada Qué
quiere decir esto normalmente estamos
acostumbrados a
lo que ha ocurrido en la historia de la
humanidad es que básicamente las mujeres
en principio han deseado tener menos
hijos en algunos casos que los hijos que
finalmente tenían eh Y los métodos
anticonceptivos jugaban un rol
fundamental para poder garantizar que se
pueda normar y se pueda trabajar y las
mujeres pueden realizar esa fecundidad
sin embargo hay ahora el fenómeno
contrario también existen países existen
mujeres que tienen menos hijos de
aquellos que quisieran tener en buena
medida debido uno a condiciones
particulares
hay países donde por ejemplo las normas
sociales de género llegan a que las
mujeres para que puedan trabajar y
participar libremente en el mercado
laboral tengan que sacrificar en
principio sus deseos de fecundidad y por
otro lado existen también condiciones
particulares desde el punto de vista
social y de acceso No es cierto recursos
económicos a facilitar sistemas de
protección social a esquemas de garantía
de derechos que también permitan y
faciliten esta fecundidad para las
parejas en el mundo incluso donde
existen relativamente de sistemas más
igualitarios en términos de las
relaciones entre hombres y mujeres
Entonces conseguir en estos contextos
que las mujeres puedan realizar su
fecundidad sin duda es un desafío y en
buena medida también implica un reto
para las sociedades que tienen que
conseguir que hacer modificaciones
dentro de sus estructuras
edad para poder garantizar que tiene más
población edad de trabajar sin embargo
en muchos países la solución viene por
el lado también de la migración Entonces
si uno no tiene la posibilidad de tener
su con los jóvenes en buena medida los
países desarrollados lo que en octavas
por tener esquemas que faciliten la
migración de personas jóvenes para que
puedan integrarse dentro de las
dinámicas laborales
efectivamente esto sucede uno de los
grandes ejemplos es Japón donde hay un
gran descenso de la natalidad y el
gobierno hace todo lo posible para
propiciar el ambiente para que se den
más natalidades sin embargo pese a Ello
hay problemas que no se han solucionado
como el acceso al agua potable o al
saneamiento que para estas alturas ya
deberían estar solucionados porque no se
ha podido atajar este problema porque
siguen existiendo estos líos
problemas porque tenemos un mundo muy
desigual Y tenemos sociedades que son
tremendamente
inequitativas para poner un ejemplo muy
específico por ejemplo América Latina en
general pierde cada año Diez mil
millones de dólares que cero punto
treinta y ocho por ciento de su pib
debido a elementos como el embarazo
adolescente Dónde se produce el embarazo
adolescente principalmente en familias
pobres y en aquellas y y básicamente
quienes tienen en verdad adolescentes en
promedio en América Latina son las
mujeres con menores niveles educativos
entonces sin duda este tipo de elementos
estructurales a los cuales nos
acostumbrado casi lo hemos vuelto parte
del paisaje están generando estas
dinámicas donde grupos de la población
están en una situación muy desventajosa
respecto a otros que tienen las
posibilidades por ejemplo diferir su
fecundidad de poder tener más educación
de tener mejores inserciones en el
mercado laboral y tener por supuesto una
vida no es cierto en el futuro con mayor
de oportunidades entonces la desigualdad
en términos ya sea por aspectos raciales
por aspectos de género por aspectos que
tienen que ver con la localización que
tiene esta población por ejemplo en
zonas Rurales y la falta de una acción
afirmativa del estado de términos de
garantizar inversiones que permitan
cerrar estas brechas es en buena medida
culpable de que todavía tengamos grandes
brechas que persisten y al mismo tiempo
tengamos situaciones y problemas de
primer mundo dentro de nuestras
sociedades al tiempo que convivimos con
problemas también de sociedades que
están en vías de desarrollo temas como
la altísima morbilidad que tenemos por
ejemplo por enfermedades diarreicas y
respiratorias en niños en ciertas partes
de nuestros países y ciertos grupos
poblacionales y por otro lado aspectos
como enfermedades crónicas degenerativas
diabetes eh enfermedades que de
cardiovasculares Y por supuesto temas
como obesidad entonces son un continente
y somos una sociedad y somos un mundo
que persiste en términos de tener estas
grandes brechas de desigualdad que son
las en gran medida aquellas que no están
permitiendo un avance adecuado y a la
velocidad que requerimos para poder
cumplir con los objetivos de desarrollo
las grandes contradicciones que hay al
tiempo que va creciendo la población
Muchísimas gracias es Pablo Salazar
Canelo se representante del fondo de
población es de las Naciones Unidas en
Guatemala que tenga un feliz día
Ángela Buen día que esté muy bien
gracias Y a nuestros televidentes
continúen con nosotros ya volvemos con
más en directo a América
[Música]